let's go next to muhammad from i can't
actually see where somewhere that starts
with the letter t where are you calling
from muhammad uh i'm from troy michigan
tri michigan
troy michigan oh okay all right muhammad
from troy go ahead
uh all right
hello uh
uh basically i wanted to
discuss with you my thoughts on
midterms
especially since
this is
probably the hopeful slash wishful
thinking but yeah uh i feel like based
on things that are happening in recent
days especially with
uh
the far right wing just
refusing to take a vaccine and
basically making up miracle cures and
disproportionately dying yeah i
hate that i have to sort of bring a
political
uh
what's the word i'm looking for
i i don't know but basically i i think
this will hurt them in the midterms let
me see if i can understand what you're
saying mohammed are you saying that at
this point
the deaths are skewing towards
republicans so much that it they might
literally kill enough voters to lose
some races is that the idea
yeah essentially yeah yeah i mean listen
theoretically
yeah but basically they're saying that
like
uh oh midterms like 2022 is going to be
a red wave here based on how things are
going right now
they are losing that red wave here
i don't know about that muhammad i'm not
so sure about that and here's the thing
about it
the turnout is typically so low in
midterms
and although there's absolutely a
partisan gap in who's dying from covid
you need that partisan gap to overwhelm
the fact that the party that loses the
white house in one year
tends to vote at a much higher rate in
that first midterm so i you're
completely right in a general sense i
don't know that that's actually the way
it's going to go i think we need to
assume there will be a red wave and make
sure we're fighting against it at every
opportunity i would be really careful
yeah i don't
well the what i was trying to say i
wasn't
i was thinking like yeah though there
will probably be like a right wave in
the sense of like oh republicans will
like
maybe take back the house and
uh
possibly
take back the senate if things go well
for them but like based on how things
are going right now
because like
people like ev everyone in like media
and otherwise were saying like 2020 was
supposed to be a blue wave here
and it was another disaster
for democrats in 2020 because
uh they lost
about over a dozen seats in the house
right they
uh barely won the senate because of
the big lie and people like lynnwood and
sydney powell
literally saying don't vote
yeah no that's a good point i think the
takeaway muhammad is we've got to not
assume the outcome and we must all go
out and vote in every race that we have
available to us muhammad from troy
michigan
i appreciate the call we are going to go
to a very short break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones in
a moment